the story of my family is one of triumph
and sacrifice how he led a revolution
against tyranny
and now it falls on my shoulders to save
my world someone from the future is
coming to destroy Krypton because we're
on from your grandson becomes the
greatest hero of the universe
[Music]
the story of my family isn't about how
he died it's about how we lived
you know what where are we going what is
the plot on Krypton it's a show that
said 200 years before the birth of
Superman there is a conspiracy that that
starts here on earth in present day and
it involves a kind of I ain't almost in
a terminator like way at a time travel
back into Krypton's past into Krypton
200 years ago to prevent the birth of
Superman is what's at the heart of this
conspiracy so the stakes of the show are
very much about the present day it's
about the here and now it's not so much
a show about these things that happened
in the past and everything you kind of
think you know about Krypton in the way
that story ends it's going to be
challenged by the way we we approach
this story so will we will be seen
classic characters from the Superman
mythos well that's and that's a big part
of playing against the expectations
because I mean this is the most beloved
superhero of all time any time you have
anything to say about who he is
who he was who he will be what happened
to him before everybody's got an opinion
we take that very seriously and we also
want to challenge people and say you
don't know how this story actually ends
in Laura this happened but as we know
from JJ's Trek and other things one
massive event can upend everything we
know and set our heroes and a very fresh
and new and relevant course and also
there will be heroes and villains from
the DC Universe you would not expect to
show up on Krypton on Krypton in our
show and that is a very exciting part of
the world building hey everybody we got
a whole bunch of Superman Krypton
prequel to break down that was probably
the best trailer so far way better than
the trailers they've dropped before this
there's a new round of the Legion ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Superman
related comment on the video they just
did their big TC A's panel so Geoff
Johns and the showrunners explained
what's going on with the characters how
they're gonna handle time travel and
which really big Justice League level
characters are gonna show up on the
series like they actually said the Green
Lantern's will be involved in the series
in some capacity eventually so if there
was any question they have pretty free
rein like they'll eventually be a
version of Superman on the TV show too
although primarily it will be set in the
past the person handing him Superman's
cape in the Detroit Tigers cap who's
trying to warn him about
what's coming someone from the future is
coming to erase Superman's timeline so
that he won't become the greatest hero
that the universe has ever known is the
Adam Strange character now because he's
not wearing his armor we don't know if
he's become the Adam Strange character
from the comics yet or if they're gonna
do that during the series like is he
going to stick around in the past they
didn't reveal that but they did tease
that they would visit other planets
besides Krypton so because they
mentioned they be doing Green Lantern
stuff eventually they'd be doing
Hawkgirl stuff I think they might do a
little bit of ranth Anna gar war because
they're just like a lot of big
space-based races that are familiar to
people Riaan Thea Naggar is just a
really easy go-to if you're gonna be
doing Adam Strange and Hawkgirl stuff
eventually now they didn't say which
episodes all these people would be
popping up in but there are 10 episodes
total and like you see the premiere date
is March 21st that's a Wednesday it's
gonna be a Wednesday night show because
there's only 10 episodes I'm assuming
that they'll air all 10 without a break
you probably noticed that his Adam
Strange was telling him about the
mysterious threat from the future that
this tentacle looking ship was flying
through outer space that looks like it
could be brainiacs skull ship so because
there's another version of Brainiac that
we know is gonna be on the show played
by this character what might end up
happening is as well to see multiple
different versions of Brainiac and it's
just this ultimate future version of
Brainiac in the previous versions of
Brainiac just complicate the matter so
like every version of Brainiac looks a
little bit different so I don't know
what the final makeup is going to look
like on this actor like if he's gonna
walk around looking human-like or if
it'll be like Brainiac 5 who's on
Supergirl right now but like I said in
all the other trailer videos you can see
a lot of the backgrounds the ships the
clothing that they wear is inspired by
the Man of Steel Justice League movie
some of you also spotted Barristan Selmy
from Game of Thrones wearing very
Superman looking a tire like he even has
a blue costume with a red cape with an S
on it so a lot of people are like wait a
minute which version of Superman is this
this is actually meant to be Sega L
who's Superman's grandfather's
grandfather
so Superman's grandfather's grandfather
is supposed to be the person that starts
thinking about the Phantom Zone
and even though jor-el is supposed to be
the person that truly discovers and
exploits the Phantom Zone it sounds like
that wolf
start on this TV show like they'll learn
of its existence but based on the pitch
for Barristan Selmy here it sounds like
they either put him in prison brand him
as a heretic or they just don't believe
him so Jeff Jones the producers said
that they would be taking advantage of
this pocket of the DC Universe and that
you know a lot about Krypton but you
don't know a lot about its history so
they can do as much stuff as they want
that's why it's a lot easier for them to
do characters like Superman a comic-book
accurate version of doomsday so it'll be
interesting to see what that looks like
or how that comes about because there's
so many characters that we haven't met
yet we really only met the main cast
like this actress here is Aleta Zod so
you can see she's about the same age as
sag l it sounds like they'll have some
sort of friendship but she's Zod's
grandmother so we'll see how much of the
game of Thrones dune big politicking
they work into this for the most part
they've explained that the house of L at
the beginning of the series is in
disgrace probably because of whatever it
is that Val L does that has something to
do with the Phantom Zone
remember the Krypton history explainer
the jor-el gave during the Man of Steel
movie it actually sounds like it's gonna
still be canon to the series a 100
thousand years i'll civilization
flourished accomplishing wonders
what happened artificial population
control has established the outposts and
space exploration were abandoned we
exhausted our natural resources as a
result our planets call became unstable
so he says they used to be a spacefaring
race but eventually they became more
isolated more senna phobic their
cultural beliefs changed in a big way it
sounds like they abandoned science most
of that we get through the jor-el
character through the Superman mythos so
when he's using the control crystal to
activate the fortress of solitude it
sounds like he's never been there before
and it's been dormant for a long long
time
the same way Superman during Man of
Steel uses the control crystal to
activate the scoutship
and it just been sitting there in the
ice for centuries but you can kind of
see the parallels that they're drawing
with Siegel at this polar location on
Krypton discovering their family's
fortresses tallit ood like Superman goes
to the Arctic to recreate the fortress
of solitude on earth so it'll be fun to
see what is inside this fortress and
what we learn about the history of their
family the version of Sehgal that we
know in the comics is a much much older
version of the character this character
will be much closer to the age Superman
was right before he put the cape on so
like you see him put his version of the
cape on like Superman puts his version
on I'm sure you have a bunch of
questions let's leave them in the
comments below they're gonna be dropping
a bunch more trailers and they'll be
doing interviews and stuff like that
before the series premiere so we'll
learn more about it but remember it's
only ten episodes for the most part
sci-fi tends to do 10 episode series but
if it's popular enough maybe they'll
give it more episodes for season 2
runaways also just aired their finale
tonight a lot of you have asked for an
Easter Egg video I'll try to get that up
as fast as possible but they've already
been renewed for season two for the most
part most Marvel shows DC shows will be
renewed for next season very few
exceptions and we'll find out about that
in the next couple of weeks so when we
know for sure when everything is renewed
or canceled I'll do an update video
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Dan Lib peacock please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there was a new round on this
video I'll announce the winner when I
post new DC I do have some new Titans to
post really soon - but click here for
brand new Deadpool
and click here for brand-new flash thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight